i can't tell you how excited i am to see
you both here the movie's getting rave
reviews people cannot stop talking about
your performance you have fans waiting
outside this building how much of a rock
star do you feel like right now
i don't know i'm still just trying to
figure out what day it is
which yeah uh yeah i probably am
sleeping as much as one of them so yeah
this does feel really good though i you
know i know how much work you put into
this that you're playing an icon but you
must feel
a bit relieved when you get so much
support not from you know just elvis
family but all the fans yeah yeah i mean
you feel you never know how
any creative endeavor is going to turn
out
and uh so we we never knew what the
outcome was going to be but you do your
best every day and um and suddenly hear
these moments of truth like when
priscilla saw the film for the first
time or
uh even sitting down and can you know
and and seeing her there and just
knowing we were about to watch the film
together and
um yeah so there's these pivotal moments
for me that just make me so happy that's
so exciting i have to tell you anytime
there's a new baslerman film come out
i'm like i'm cnn i'm such a huge fan of
yours oh oh yes and you did such a great
job with this how did you know austin
was the one i mean obviously he's the
man for the job but how did you know
that you know when he walked in you're
like that's elvis
i mean there's a there's a story out
there now and it's true we can speak
more openly about it but it was not a
normal casting process
i got this videotape this young guy he
was in a bathrobe we laughed because in
my mind i get a bit you see my movies
they get a bit exaggerated he was it a
white piano but it was not what was not
right this is the video you sent in yeah
yeah are you in a row yeah but but
here's the thing he was playing
unchained melody which is the final time
ever sings in the movie
he's crying up to the heavens
and it didn't feel auditioning it didn't
feel like someone's saying hey look look
what i can do
and i later find out what it is and
probably osteotomic story but he'd had a
terrible
emotional experience
and he just put it into this piece of
tape now that caught my attention
it's true i got a call from denzel
washington as
aust was coming in
to say who i do not know denzel
washington and he said look i've rung
you to tell you you're about to meet a
young actor whose work ethic is like no
other
which turned out to be true
oz came in he was already down elvis
presley boulevard a bit in terms of
character and voice
i said at that stage look i pretty much
need you to sing the young elvis how do
you think you go with that and honestly
that went so well
that recently i've had to put a costume
test out on tick tock just to show
people him unplugged and unmarked just
singing
but for me from that moment it wasn't
like boom you're the guy i don't think i
ever really thought about it it i just
kept putting him through his bases and
really building a structure around him
for to flourish what he'd already
brought in he'd already brought in
a level of characterization and journey
towards the soul of elvis that i just
helped him continue
that is a good story denzel washington
okay
that's amazing was it like hearing that
did you tell this yeah
no
the thing is i i just said this before
it's it's the thing denzel's my hero
and uh i still can't believe he knows my
name you know so the fact that he would
call on my behalf it just means the
world to me okay so from the voice the
moves the singing what did you work the
hardest on to perfect
that's really hard to quantify because
it it's it's how it all fits together
and that the fact that
they're very specific things and some
things are very technical
uh you know i've spent hours with my
movement coach polly bennett who uh is
it was just my a rock to me during this
whole process
um bazz and i had so many
uh
moments where we would just talk through
moments of elvis life and it helps you
just put into context and
um i i had a number of different dialect
coaches that i worked with and singing
coaches and the karate instructor and i
i had these days structured out for
a year and a half but though i had six
months during covert which was probably
uh
the pivotal moment for me as far as
suddenly nobody's knocking at my door
nobody's telling me you have to be at
this meeting at this time and this was
six months where i just could follow my
curiosity every day and that's really
when it felt like everything began to
settle mm-hmm you know i know you're not
huge on social media but you you know
you know by and everyone's obsessed with
your elvis accent like people can't get
enough uh who in your family had the
best reaction the first time they heard
that elvis accent
uh
i i think
you know it's probably my sister when i
would call her on the phone and she
would she would hear me talking why is
chair so i wasn't sure if it was me
i figured out a different way of sitting
on this
yeah probably my sister yeah
and she and would she be someone that
you would call to just test things out
or just it was nice no it's just when i
would call her and see how she was doing
and stuff it happened to be sort of the
voice that i was speaking in is she like
is this you or is this elvis it's it's
that funny thing when you're when you're
praying when you're practicing
uh with with i mean i wouldn't
i wouldn't always work with this way but
with elvis you run the risk of being a
caricature the whole time there's so
many traps that you can fall into so for
me i doubled down on anything that i
could do that made it feel like this is
life this is you know a man who wakes up
in the morning and brushes his teeth and
goes through the world and has to eat
breakfast and all those little mundane
things so for me it was kind of a
process of of
seeing what that feels like in life you
know uh so yeah so i mean it seems
ridiculous every time you talk about
acting you run the risk of sounding
incredibly pretentious and
self-important so i'm always kind of
like uh embarrassed talking about it but
not after this performance you can
literally say anything you want after
this performance seriously because
everyone just wants to know how you did
it because you're so freaking good in it
yeah seriously uh a basilarman film is
not complete without an amazing
soundtrack obviously elvis but you have
such amazing artists
look i do i have a lot of you see a lot
of it austin singing novice you hear a
lot of real elvis and then to translate
some of the feelings for a younger
audience we've got great artists from
you know eminem drop the track yesterday
manoskin dropped the track last night um
you know doger cat obviously translating
the worlds of round dog i tell you
something about the music if you like my
films and you said you like them they do
you know i make them for the movies i
made him to go out into a cinema and be
with a crowd and what's been really
gratifying for me and i'm not an easy
person to go oh i'm so happy but
from the moment we screened it in can
and alton mason came on at little
richard people started applauding
at the performances right through to the
elvis performances as if they were at a
rock show and i'm noticing people say to
me i felt like i actually experienced
being in a live
rock show with elvis performing and
wanting to emote and applaud and get
into it and i think that's exciting
because we even have that on the
soundtrack we have some classic elvis
performing in the vegas show you know so
there's a such a variety of music in the
whole piece yeah yeah it was so
impressive seeing all the artists
contributing to the soundtrack casey
musgraves too
falling in love oh yes
so good stevie nicks
the
more impressive than the other uh do you
have a favorite elvis song i answer it
differently every day ah okay so what's
with one today i uh
um
yeah i mean earlier i said american
trilogy
i just i love that song so much but then
as we were on the drive over here i
thought of if i can dream
and just what that song means and how
powerful that is and
um yeah it's hard to choose just one i
know it's like picking your favorite kid
everyone has one mom everyone i'm just
kidding i'm just kidding i don't have
kids i have no idea um can we talk i do
and you never say that no you're not
supposed to say that right you said i
love you
my mom maybe had favorites you do i love
you equally but differently yeah yeah i
heard that a lot i heard that a lot
growing up uh can we talk tom hanks i'm
recognizable yeah so good in this role
and i've seen him with you on red
carpets it sounds like he's um
like almost looking after you or he
seems a bit protective in like such a
kind of fatherly way did you feel that
support on set absolutely i did he's
just he's the greatest he's so kind and
uh and he's been so uh
he's just such a great mentor you know
he's been doing it for so long
and and he still works so hard and he's
excited by it and uh
and yeah he's just such a lovely person
he never goes to his trailer on set no
no most actors just go back to the
trailer you know never he sits on set
reads the paper talks a lot with austin
yeah i've never actually had it where
two actors sit around while we're doing
resets and so that talking
in costume like hates going back to the
trailer la i saw one night we were in a
casino scene and tom i would turn around
and he was playing um craps with the
extras on a table oh my god like
seriously he was gambling with them you
know so the rumors are true he's one of
the nicest guys in hollywood
yeah but he's also a leader like he
brings
leadership energy
he we had a discussion the other night
and we all went out to dinner he said
like i mean he likes people
you know he does he's not one of these
guys want to hide under a think of who
i'm talking you know he likes to be out
amongst it to the to degree you can do
it without you know they're being
troubled yeah well guys such a pleasure
getting to talk to you uh i wore my
fancy blazer pink suit for you
thank you
i got you thanks so much
you